salut les bitches sa femme s'est pas dit
si toi moi je viens de nice écoute moi
bien pom boys ici c'est pas ton pote
c'est secret door 2 door
alors va jouer dans le sable avec ton
souhait taquet kate avant que je t'ai
trip est ce que tu es d'accord lui que
méchant ça par exemple jamais faire un
jeu m'avait regardé
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien voir ta
gueule mais juste un soir pour halloween
e
oui
petite tache l'un le trou cerveau en fin
à la partie active qui représentent
environ 7%
et comme pour donner un ordre d'idée une
huître 6,8 milliards à 9 c 9
il ya des gens qui vont chercher sa
souplesse
bonjour avez vous à hossegor ah ben moi
aussi monté mais non mais je vais
trouver mieux
et le tout est de la tête tu trouveras
la plage de faire peur à ces gentils
toutous de la gueule non juste de ta
voix